I don't think you think about building a
company.
I think you think about building a
product.
A lot of people ask me
the dieting,
how did you start a company?
And I always responded,
we never started a company.
A company is a byproduct of making a
great product.
We made six bags for Kate.
We made two for Jack and made them
really well and slowly but surely,
um,
found an audience for those bags,
sold them to the right stores who had
the customers who we believed would
appreciate those.
So we limited the distribution.
Um,
let it kind of go where it,
where would go naturally and really
focused on the product.
I mean,
if you focus on the product and you
watch the market and you understand
where there are voids and you find
something that's new that satisfies a
need,
it's,
it's so old school and simple,
um,
and be consistent about it and watch
quality,
hire great people.
Really stay true to your original vision
and then just expand on it.
Um,
then you have a company and a brand,
uh,
France take a long time.
You can't build history into something
we can't compete with.
The Europeans have been around a hundred
years,
so we have to be more innovative and a
little bit more clever and intelligent.
Um,
because no one believes something's well
made when it's two years old,
you know?
Um,
if you're a hundred year old company
still going,
you obviously know what you're doing.
Does that make sense?